hello everybody and welcome to another
python series uh this series is gonna be
dedicated to robotics with python so one
of the coolest things i think you can do
with programming is bring your
programming to life physically through
robotics
uh so with that we're gonna do use our
raspberry pi
and do some robotics with it so notably
most people use the arduino for robotics
just really the arduino is just older
and more mature than the raspberry pi
but i think the raspberry pi is
definitely a serious contender for
robotics especially because the
raspberry pi
uh has more uh software ability at least
easier than the arduino has so the
arduino and the raspberry pi are
actually two very different things right
the the arduino is just a controller the
raspberry pi is a computer so they kind
of do two totally different things
just so happens that the raspberry pi
has gpi gpio pins and we can use them
so with that let's go ahead and get
started talking about the things that we
need all right so obviously uh you need
a raspberry pi uh you want raspbian
installed if you use noobs to install
raspbian you should already have rpi
gpio installed i will put a the command
in the description however run that
command make sure you actually do have
gpio installed so we can control the
gpio pins via python
so you'll need that you'll need a
battery pack
because the raspberry pi supplies a max
of 3.3 volts
which is uh obviously not enough most
motors want at least double that so you
want a battery pack for that and once
you do that you're going to need a board
to control that and our choice of board
is this h bridge
see if we can get it to
focus on it there we go
um this board is specifically the l298n
this one's made by sandsmart depending
on where you buy it uh the actual
architecture well not that i guess
architecture's a bad word but the
structure of it uh might be slightly
different but you should be able to buy
any l298n and follow along with us again
this one's from st smart came with a kit
that i bought and i will put the links
and talk more about that kit in a second
also
um you'll need a motor and wheels the
wheels come with the motor usually you
can buy these on ebay like four of these
for 10 bucks or something so pretty
cheap
my only complaint about these is a
pretty weak but for your first project
they're okay
the other things that you're going to
need you're going to have some wiring
black and red helps just to keep
yourself sane
and then obviously you're going to want
some wire cutters and wire strippers so
you can strip the end of the wires
along with wires you're going to want
both
male to female and then also you want
some female to female most likely jumper
wires
so i suggest you get those
and then from there
and just as an aside if you don't have
female to female it's okay
you can always use
two male to females cut off the male
part and splice the two together
so that's that there's also like female
adapters that you can slide onto the end
of a male to female or even you can just
use regular wires and wrap them around
do whatever you want
for this in the basics we're not going
to do any soldering
eventually you do want to do some
soldering uh just so your connections
are a lot more secure but since this is
your first little kit that you're
putting together i don't really suggest
you use any soldering just because
you're probably going to take it apart
and do something else with it
so i don't really suggest it so i would
just use regular wires and have some
electrical tape or something to wrap it
up
so with that that should be all the
basics that you need obviously you're
going to want like some sort of frame
for your car again i bought a kit you
can buy that kit on sane smart and get
all the parts that you need for like 40
bucks and then buy the bridge for i
think it's like nine bucks
but you can also go to ebay buy the
bridge buy the motors buy the battery
pack
um and then go to like sears and you can
just you can build a frame yourself you
know so you can get the parts and they
have you know holes in them and you can
you could build the frame if you wanted
on your own i just thought it'd be
easiest to use the frame plus i didn't
have the battery pack the motors and
anything else so i thought might as well
go for it so i will put links in the
description for that stuff um
next the only other thing i'll add i
think before i conclude this for parts
that you need
i would suggest you get one of these
i'll put the link in the description for
this edimax uh it's a wireless adapter
for your pi
uh you just want one that doesn't
require any driver installations for the
most part this one plug and play so
definitely highly recommend it um also
yeah you'll want a one of these uh it's
just a portable power supply for the pi
uh this is an anchor and i bought the
3000
but it supplies 5 volts at 1 000
milliamps so that's exactly what we
wanted and i have no idea how long it
lasts but it lasts more than an hour
so that's as good as i have for now for
you but that's pretty good so to power
your pi for more than an hour and these
i'm not really sure if you ran the motor
um i've definitely logged probably an
hour's worth on the motors though and i
did just check this one has like you
know those little things you can push on
the battery to see how much juice it
still has and it was still percent so
um apparently this will last a while too
because these motors are [ __ ] motors
so those are the parts that you need um
and really that's that's it for now uh
in the next video what we're gonna be
doing is controlling this motor the idea
of this h-bridge is that not only can
you control the motor with it using the
battery pack for power
but with the h-bridge what you can do is
not only make the motor go but you can
reverse the motor if the motor is
capable of reverse so we can make the
motor go forward or go backward or not
go
so that's obviously very helpful
so yeah so that's what we'll be doing
the next video we'll be actually
programming
our motor and then from there we'll
program all the motors together to work
you know in synchronization so they can
turn and all that because we don't have
anything that's going to like pivot the
wheel for us
so yeah so that'll be a whole lot of fun
it'll be a hoot
so
anyway uh that's at with this video
that's what you have to look for in the
next video as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time